ah
[Música]
cómo
desde la plaza black light mar hasta
minneapolis desde los ángeles hasta
nueva york y en las principales ciudades
del país estadounidenses salieron a
marchar como lo hicieron hace un año
para conmemorar la muerte de georg floyd
y pedir justicia por los casos no
resueltos de homicidios y de abuso
policial contra otros afroamericanos
queremos que algo salga desde washington
han dicho activistas y manifestantes en
referencia a la ley de reforma policial
que se está debatiendo en este momento
en el congreso y que precisamente lleva
el nombre de georgia florida
con esta reforma policial piden entre
otras cosas prohibir los
estrangulamientos parar los
allanamientos no autorizados y acabar
con la inmunidad calificada para los
oficiales de la policía acusados de
crímenes
hay que mencionar que yo bailé invito a
la casa blanca a la hermana a la hija y
a la madre de la hija de george o floyd
[Música]
en españa el racismo y la xenofobia
siguen existiendo lo vimos en ceuta
españa ha conseguido devolver a
marruecos la gran mayoría de los 9000
inmigrantes ilegales que cruzaron la
frontera pero el partido de extrema
derecha a box sigue tratando de
rentabilizar la crisis
el lunes organizó una manifestación en
ceuta saltándose las prohibiciones de
los tribunales el líder de box habló de
una invasión de soldados enviados por
marruecos en españa el peso de los
estereotipos sigue importantes según un
informe del gobierno fueron
entrevistadas personas de varios grupos
étnicos viviendo en españa más de la
mitad de ellas dicen haber sufrido una
discriminación ese informe también pone
de manifiesto un incremento del racismo
en todos los ámbitos especialmente en el
acceso a la vivienda en la educación y
en el trato de las fuerzas de seguridad
del estado
[Música]
brasil fue uno de los últimos países del
mundo en prohibir la esclavitud en 1888
hoy el país más grande de américa latina
tiene más de la mitad de la población
que se declara negra es decir el 56 por
ciento a pesar de este dado el racismo
estructural todavía es una lacra que se
traduce en desigualdad y muchas veces en
muertes el año pasado según datos
oficiales el 78 por ciento de las
personas muertas a manos de la policía
eran negras además en las universidades
sólo el 11 por ciento de los negros
consiguen finalizar los estudios en las
empresas brasileñas las personas en
posición de liderazgo negras representan
menos del 30 por ciento y en el
congreso- tanto el parlamento como el
senado hay sólo un 18% de negros
resultado de las últimas elecciones de
2018 datos estos que muestran que brasil
está lejos todavía de disfrutar de una
igualdad racial
[Música]